[dramatic music]
- Protecting a pope who wants
to be accessible to the public
is never an easy task.
Unlike other world leaders
who are very conscious
of their threat,
the pope feels
that it's part of his mission
to be a man of the people,
especially this pope.
- The security
is given the task
of protecting him,
and they're saying,
"Well, how can we protect you
if you get out of that car?"
And he's saying, "Well,
how can I be with the people
unless I do get out
of the car?"
- The protection of the pope
has a rich history to it.
During the assassination
attempt of John Paul II,
the popemobile was simply
a jeep-type vehicle
with a roll bar,
and the pope
would stand on a platform
and wave.
[gunshot]
Because of the assassination
attempt,
they built a vehicle that,
one, was armored;
two, rose him on a platform
surrounded by plexiglass.
So he was still
in an open top,
but if shots rang out,
they'd be likely
to shoot from below,
and they'd be hitting
the plexi.
It would give the Swiss Guard
the opportunity
to pull him down off the steps
and protect him.
This would be great if Francis
was willing to use it.
♪ ♪
- Pope Francis didn't want
to be behind
bulletproof glass,
so his popemobile is often
just in the back of kind of
a pickup truck, essentially,
going through the crowds.
When he travels, Pope Francis
likes to be in a FIAT
or in sort of
a cheap moderate car
because he doesn't want
to be seen in a fancy car.
- So the United States
Secret Service
had a challenge in this.
The pope visited us in 2015,
the first stop being
Washington, D.C.
Protecting the president
of the United States,
of course,
is a very complicated job.
But in a lot of ways,
protecting the pope
is a lot more complicated.
The FIAT in question that
he rode in was not armored.
Matter of fact, it was donated
by a local dealer.
It's a small FIAT 500
four-door hatchback,
which is not the norm
in a Secret Service motorcade.
Therefore, what they had to do
was flank the vehicle
on either side
by armored
Secret Service SUVs.
They were Chevy Suburbans.
And in doing so,
they created, basically,
a block that, if someone
was to attack the motorcade,
they could converge on
and get him out of there.
- As long as he can
touch the people,
as long as he can
kiss the babies,
shake the hands
of the elderly
and of the disabled people,
he really doesn't care
if he's safe or not.
♪ ♪